the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we have a list l originally life
answer 42 and 0 in this example if you
don't know Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy
that's why 42 is important as as a
scientist if I didn't have example 1 at
least one example with the number 42 I'd
probably hear about it
so here it is okay so we have this
original list L which contains the
string life the string answer 42 the
number 42 and the number zero here I'm
writing a loop that iterates over every
element directly in L right so I'm so
originally thing I originally thing is
going to be a string life then thing is
going to be the string answer then thing
is going to be the number 42 and so what
am i doing inside the loop as I'm
iterating
well if thing is equal to zero that I'm
going to do this and otherwise I'm gonna
do this so for the first two iterations
when thing is equal to life for answer
I'm not doing anything as soon as I hit
42 though I'm saying L at position 1 is
going to get this value here okay so
when I've iterated over this element
here I'm saying L at position 1 I'm
gonna change its value which says well
I'm gonna keep life the same but this is
going to be everything and then we're
keeping the rest the same 42 and 0
because we're only modifying L at
position 1 as soon as we do that we've
finished with the loop when L was 42 and
then we go through 0 so now thing takes
on the value 0 and we say if thing is
equal to 0 well we're good on that L at
position thing is equal to universe so L
at position 0 is equal to universe so
that says ok I'm gonna replace life with
universe and then everything else stays
the same 42
and zero okay so that would be my answer
universe everything 42 and zero great
that's the majority good job